hey there i'm james steinbach and i'm
really excited to be speaking with you
today about an emberdo's guide to css
grid
css grid is a really awesome cool
and powerful block of css
it gives us a lot of powerful tools
we've never had in any css layout method
until now this combination has not
existed until today
and by today i mean 2017 when all the
major browsers
shipped full grid support grid gives us
a responsive css only layout method
it only needs grid styles floats clear
fixes don't need that
inline block white space problems don't
have to hack those
only grid styles it allows precise
control of columns
rows and gaps in our grid and allows us
to position children
anywhere we need to however as
a spider-man said with great power comes
great responsibility
with grid with great power comes great
complexity and this slide is full of
little words
not because i want you to read them all
but i'm not very thoughtful about
legibility no because i don't need you
to read them all i just want us to
collectively
feel the weight of this wall of text
right it's a lot
and especially if you're not a css
specialist or expert if your day-to-day
is consumed with a lot of normal
javascript things
working on frameworks uh release updates
for
ember refactoring a bunch of components
to use glimmer
uh getting all octanefied in your
projects great great great great great
you
don't have time probably to focus on 30
new css properties
and not all of them are new some are
from flexbox but if you've got sharp
eyes and you're paying attention
the flexbox properties are all the same
ones that you always have to look up on
css tricks every time with that cool
little visualization they've got
bookmarked there
it's not the easy flexbox it's the
tricky ones
so this is like trying to drive to the
horizon down this road and we're not
going to do that
i want to get to the end of the road but
i don't want anybody you know to get
motion sick
so we're going to trim it down we're
going to learn seven things today
and these seven things you see on your
screen now are going to give us the vast
majority of the power we need
and i'm going to make a big promise to
build almost any grid you need in real
life
that's a big promise but i think it's
going to hold true so let's look at this
optimized road let's hit the horizon
on that path so without further ado the
short happy path
to grid we'll look at code first and
then we'll break it down and learn what
all these lines mean
display grid is a starting point uh just
like display flex
it's the right way to tell the browser
hey use grid layout algorithm
on this component or element to lay out
all of its children
not grandchildren just immediate
children we're going to provide some
measurements for the columns and i'll
show you what
fr means in a moment we're going to
define some areas we're going to name
the spaces or we can put an element
there are four names
header content sidebar and footer
remember those because we're going to
see them on the very next slide
and we're going to put gaps between rows
and columns
and you think that's a lot of complexity
on the parents what did it do to the
children
actually grid moves the complexity with
css grid all the measurements all the
layouts all the rules
all the constraints live on the parent
and all the children need to do
is get told which area to fit themselves
in and all the words in grid area here
are part of grid template areas on the
previous slide
so really powerful stuff you don't have
to define a ton of math and a ton of
measurements and a ton of margins and
percent based width and all that on the
children we're moving all that
complexity off of the children
onto the parent the grid itself which is
really awesome it makes our code so much
cleaner
because we're not searching through
three or four different selector blocks
to find width and measurements
we're scanning four different selector
blocks to find a named area
all the measurements all the complexity
is defined on the grid itself
and children just are told where to go
very cool method here so let's look at
these properties we put into a grid
container
see what we got well grid template
columns is the first thing
display grid is a given we've already
mentioned that but let's look at how to
measure columns
columns set the proportions for tracks
along the inline axis of the grid
container
and you think why don't you say
horizontal james or just say columns is
it too many fancy words just say columns
i respect that and i'll show you in a
second why i'm calling it an inline axis
it's a new evolution in css
that is actually going to be very
powerful once it's widely supported
but this gives us our column
measurements and the value we use is any
valid length values
in a space separated series for example
you can do 30 and 150 pixels and 30
and unlike flexbox if you don't use up
all your grid space and you define your
columns
grid's like that's cool i don't mind
empty space i'm not afraid of the
silence
flexbox is like no silence i'ma stretch
things unless you tell me not to
and so grid is different from flexbox in
that regard your precision stands
without being artificially
stretched or squished however if you
want to use up your empty space
fractional units are a really cool way
to do that we hold our next code grid
template columns
one fraction 12 m's eight m's and a
fraction
12 and eight are kind of fixed
measurements they're relative to the
font size but
uh they're fixed in that grid and after
they're used up
grid goes okay in the parent is there
still empty space
are 12 and 8 m's leaving room cool
if i've got a fraction at the beginning
and a fraction at the end that's two
fractions
i've got to divide all the remaining
space in i give one out of two here
and one out of two here or split into
halves
and what we've got here is a
self-centering layout the 12m and 8m
columns are always going to be put
together
centered in the middle of the grid
pretty cool stuff
grid template rows works essentially the
same way but whereas
columns operate along the inline axis
rows operate along the block axis and
again in a second i'll show you why i'm
saying inline and block
and not top bottom left right those kind
of words
same value and look at examples we could
do a fraction and then two fractions
here the top row is wide and tall enough
for its content and the second row is
twice as tall
1 and 2. here we've got a repeat
function which is a cool new trick
our top row is 50 pixels tall and all
the rows that follow are 100 pixels tall
uh neat little way to do something like
a um you know
table layout if you're building like an
editor an admin interface
for something your all your titles would
go in a little 50 pixels column
and then each of your rows with a whole
bunch more data would be taller below it
but having shown you pixels on that
screen i'm going to now turn around and
say
oh go easy on the pixels though okay
so i want to give you a warning about
fixed heights fixed heights really
easily cause
overflow if your content is longer than
whatever 100 pixels makes room for
it's going to flow through the margin
least bad problem
flow down into the next row not into
like the element but like
covering up or obscuring part of the
next row
next decentest option worst option get
covered up by the next row or obscured
by an overflow hidden property on its
own
row accessibility is not just something
we do
for people who have what we perceive
from our
privileged spot as lowered ability okay
accessibility is for everybody
fixed heights on gridrows creates
accessibility problems
for users of 2020 vision it's not a
matter of limitation on them
if we program things wrong we create
legibility and accessibility problems so
accessibility is for everyone not in us
versus them
kindness of our heart aren't we special
give ourselves a star proposition
it's just building the web for people
okay
grid is going to automatically protect
your content unless you put a fixed
height on
that's an awesome part of the web so use
flexible
values for your row heights like auto
and min content and max content
fractional units are pretty decent too
logical properties quick sidebar the
reason i've said inline and block
is because we've got a new way of
thinking about where things are located
and what directions things go in css
this is an evolution of
the spec for a long time everything
we've positioned we've described
with physical properties these are
related to the viewport the device
itself
top right bottom left those break down
really quickly right
what if you build a website and you
start translating it and you cover most
of europe with your languages like
french and german and dutch and
a handful of others and it's all left to
right you got english and all those
european languages and you're pretty
covered right
and then marketing and bizdev decide hey
we're expanding our market into
the middle east as well and we're going
to have users who read in hebrew and
arabic
and now we need to be able to support
the same site but our layout has to be
right to left
well suddenly our physical property
words right and left no longer makes
sense they no longer accurately describe
where content is
and we have to find a way to reverse all
our margin rights and border rights and
all those things because we need them
all on the left now
one more complexity not all languages
are horizontal
okay all of our left right languages
which probably cover the majority of
people in the room
room today all of our
right to left languages as well it's all
horizontal so inline is a start
to end of a line of text inside of an
element
that's horizontal those are horizontal
languages and block is a start to the
end of a block of text like a full
paragraph worth
if you decide to continue expanding your
market in this hypothetical app we're
talking about
and now you're bringing in farther east
countries and you're
expanding all the way out into china and
korea and japan
and you've introduced a handful of
dialects now that have column
text their writing mode is vertical now
the start to the end of a line of text
is a vertical line
not a horizontal one and the start to
the end of a block of text
is a horizontal line not a vertical one
grid automatically responds
in this in the slides that follow i'm
not going to change the css at all i
promise i'm only going to put
different attributes or in one case a
css property on a wrapper element
i'm not going to change the grid code at
all
here's direction left to right here's
direction right to left i didn't change
the grid code at all it automatically
turned it all around
whoa how sweet right to left support for
free
yes and now one more writing mode
vertical left right
you can see the browser rotated the text
automatically even though the characters
are still english characters
latin characters it rotated the text and
the entire layout
i did not change the grid css at all i
just put this property on a wrapper
amazing that's all we did grid gives you
so much responsiveness
for free this is amazing so
we've made rows we've made columns back
to grid
let's name those intersections
when we use white space that's cool and
i'll show you why white space is cool on
the next slide
and if you need to create a blank cell
in a grid template you can use a period
for that
so here we are same thing we saw back at
the beginning
header is one grid area that spans four
columns and fills one row
we've got a gap and a gap in between
them body and sidebar
and then we've got footer much like
headers spanning four rows one area
though one element will be assigned to
footer
one element assigned to header and
notice what i said about white space
i've got a couple spaces after that
third header and the third footer a few
extra spaces after body and a whole
bunch of extra spaces after each period
why did i do that it's cool that grid
doesn't mind how many spaces you use
because
you cannot just program your grid you
can draw your grid directly in grid
template areas
and the outcome will look like the css
that's powerful if you are a visual
learner or identifier of things
this is going to rock your world this is
super duper look at your css
that's what the page is going to look
like it's right there
love it you can go a little more ascii
artist and use
emoji but i don't recommend that it's
harder to read you run into problems
with contrast in most text editors
between light and dark mode
uh and your you know zero or mono space
fonts don't apply anymore with emojis
and you might even run into a browser
implementation issue with unicode
mapping
but a couple limitations on grid
template areas a named area can only be
one rectangle
it can't be an l shape it can't be like
a stair step kind of try to make a fake
diagonal
all the cells have to be adjacent you
can't start a named area here continue
it here and then put a little more down
here
and expect content to kind of flow
between them and those breaks
uh what you're describing is a whole
different css spec it's real though it's
called css regions and it doesn't exist
in browsers yet
it's been under discussion forever yeah
sorry
and grid template areas their names have
to be strings that start with letters
not numbers if you start a grid template
area name with a number like
1a that's not going to work a1 is good
and when we look at the children
we'll see why we can't use a number for
a named area as the first character
but for now just trust me don't do it
okay a bonus sorry i said there are
seven here's a here's a bonus
grid template is just a shorthand though
so it's essentially summing up what
we've already learned
you can put grid template columns
template rows and grid template areas
those three properties
all in one shorthand it's kind of like
background containing background color
background image background position
background
size and a couple others all three
properties you can put into
one property and now what have we done
this is amazing this i just love this
so much this is where i start when i
write css grid
you can not only look at your code and
see exactly how your layout is going to
turn out
uh disclaimer your your editor is not
going to highlight with orange and blue
that would be a really cool vs code
extension if somebody could make it
though
that'd be really nifty your code editor
is not going to highlight like that
but not only can you visualize the
entire grid layout that the browser is
going to render
every row ends with its height every
column ends with its width
all the relevant information to rows
columns and their proportions is
right there in one chunk of css
that is amazing that is boiling down a
lot of complicated stuff
to a very readable readable identifiable
manageable chunk of css
that visually matches the end result on
your browser window
i love this so much i'm so excited this
is how i love grid
this is what i do and you can make gaps
too
gaps are a space that exists between
columns or between rows
used to be called grid gap you might
remember that if you've seen tutorials
for a year or two
but grid gap has been deprecated and air
quote is a name it's css nothing ever
gets deprecated for real
but it's now just called gap because
flexbox is going to be supporting gap
between children firefox already has
that support
chromium and the webkit are hopefully
hopefully not far behind
it's a shorthand for the row gap 20
pixels and then the column gap
30 pixels but like margin it's also a
self-expanding shorthand so if you just
say gap
10 pixels you'll get 10 between rows and
between columns
that's it that's all the new properties
you need to know to build a grid
container
i showed you a couple new values on the
way in those slides so let's dig into
those two now
fraction and repeat fraction is one
fraction of the grid's
free space what is free space
it's whatever pixels are left after all
the non-fractional units
column measurements or row measurements
have been used up
so after you calculate your gaps after
you calculate all of your
pixel and viewport width and m and rem
and percent
based column widths anything left in the
parent grid
is available as free space for
fractional units to divvy up
based on the total number of fractional
units you've put in your grid row
or grid template row grid template
column property grid is going to divide
the free space into that many units and
then portion it out
appropriately words are great but let's
look at code instead
here's 300 pixels in the first column
and then one fraction it's super greedy
it just gobbles up the rest of the empty
space
if we put this in a container that was
only 300 pixels wide
one fraction would effectively be zero
pixels wide because there's no pixels
left to divvy up
here's our self-centering layout once
again 12 m's and eight m's are
non-fractional units there they and the
gaps are divided out first
and then everything left gets divided
into half a chunk here and half a chunk
there
you can even do a column layout that's
all based on fractions
here the browser says you've given me
six units to divide up one plus two plus
three
so all the space is free except for a
couple gaps i'm going to divide the rest
of that
pixel value into six one for the first
column
two sixths for the second column and
three sixths for the final column
a very uh much simpler way i think to
program
proportional grids without having to get
into percentages and decimals
and complicated math especially division
by three related stuff so let's
walk through that all in one shot let's
build a grid from scratch here's a blank
grid
it's got four columns all squished
together on the edge they're just barely
wide enough to have a little bit of
color
so let's add gaps cool thank you browser
you put gaps in i love it
let's give the second and third column
better width
i'd say fifty percent of the parent for
the first cop or the the wider column
and twenty-five percent of the parent
for the narrow column
awesome columns one and four still empty
let's change them from zero to one
fraction
and now the layout self centers and we
can go ahead and add in some rows we've
got a header and a footer
and this is the the code we've been
looking at like all day long more or
less
only with some fixed rows just to give
it space in the demo
we've just built a non-trivial layout
you may say this is really simple that's
like every blog like
most wordpress themes am i right let's
make fun of wordpress too
no we won't do that but this is actually
a specific layout from css lore if you
will it's called the holy grail of css
layout
and for like a decade css blogs and
tutorials
have walked through different layout
options and techniques and said
how well can that layout layout
technique accomplish this
thing full with header and footer
centered layout
with a wide content and a narrow sidebar
and the content inside bar the same
height so the background colors can
extend all the way from top to bottom
we just learned how to do it in grid in
about 15 minutes of looking at code
and 30 seconds of walking through an
animation
i hesitate to use the word easy but
it would be hard to see how grid could
make that simpler
this is very manageable and uh a really
powerful
thing we can do with not a ton of syntax
and not a lot of code written
i love grid we also saw repeat earlier
as you might have guessed it repeats a
certain length
certain number of times so repeat 12
times one fraction
anyway 12 equal columns let's pretend
there's a 20 pixel gap too
is bootstrap and this is a really neat
way you can basically migrate grids off
of bootstrap and into pure css if you
need to
so grid child properties everything
we've just looked at all of those things
properties and couple values that's all
for the parent
what do we put on the child however
buckle up
i've got a whole slide in this section
grid area that's all
what value do we use a grid template
area's name that we already set on the
parent
now here's a quick caveat here's why we
can't use numbers as the first character
of a named
area grid template area accepts a
different kind of value which is up to
four integers
separated by slashes and those are
manual row
columns start and end values
if you start a grid area with the number
two oops
browser is going to be like oh two are
we doing our row start
and if you do like two dash a it will
actually say no that's actually invalid
syntax it needs to be a letter prefixed
string
and you can't just say two because the
browser is going to go oh row start too
let's do it man
so yeah please don't but grid area all
you need and you need a named grid
uh named area string from your grid
template areas property
and it's all we have to do with the
children that's all we have to do with
the children
so congrats everybody y'all know grid
i'm proud of you
give yourselves a round of applause okay
it sounds really feeble just
me standing in my basement clapping
sorry uh but if you're all clapping at
home too
then we'll just have a huge amount of
clapping in the world and it will be
beautiful
so before we go let's dig into a couple
practical examples
everybody wants to know how do you
center a grid in css hahaha stack
overflow joke peter griffin meme
moving along three lines of code in grid
also
incidentally same three lines of code in
flexbox but you start with display flex
you just put these three properties on
the parent and one element inside of it
will automatically be centered as long
as the parent is taller and wider than
it
cool it's not a joke anymore it's
actually really manageable
cool let's do something uh non-trivial
though
back to the idea we've got an admin
interface maybe we're letting people
edit blog posts or some other kind of
published content
here we've got a grid we cannot set up
our rows
and columns on the wrapper element that
contains all these rows
and then get children of each row
element to respect the columns
that's like that's grandchildren kind of
generations and we can't do that with
grid yet
subgrid is coming it's in firefox and
chromium i think behind a flag in
one or both browsers and hopefully
webkit eventually
uh hopefully quickly really and once we
have sub good we will be able to do that
but for now what we're going to do is
we're going to make each row in this
table
i use table and you know air quotes it's
not an actual table element
each row is going to be display grid on
its own
we've got two rows title and date
actions and status
that's pretty self-explanatory each of
their heights is auto whatever it needs
for the words
then we've got a fraction as the width
of the title and action column
and then the date and the status tag are
max content and max content is a cool
new keyword in grid
essentially what max content says is i
want the maximum width
this content could be if we don't create
any line breaks or hyphenation
don't go wider than that don't go wider
than the max content just how wide will
it be if we don't artificially break any
lines or words
so if we had may 1st as a publication
date the word published would not be
hyphenated even if we had a really
narrow viewport or a really wide element
in the next column
pushing it over we'll never line break
between february and 19th of that
property
instead if our post title gets really
long it will line break
and that's a more legible way to go for
things let the post title have the break
and don't force your your date to wrap
and then we've got a half a gap half a
rem gap between everything
let's get a little more complicated
let's take a responsive component for
example
some of you are saying wait wait a
second don't you take grid this is
columns
james this is only columns you put a
wrapper around photo and bio you put a
wrapper a div around
the header which contains name title and
contact and awards those four elements
two wrappers one for each pair of
elements boom you're done you don't need
grid for this you see flexbox you can
even float that
get out of here the grid talk okay oh
i'm sad um but actually i'm going to
fool you for a second this is all laid
out with grid without wrapper divs and
the reason for wrapper divs will become
apparent
in a couple slides but here's what the
grid looks like
there actually are rows photo and awards
are allowed to overlap and share that
second row with each other so we don't
see a single
full width row gap dividing the entire
layout
we're kind of smooshing past each other
and creating the illusion of there not
being rows
the column with photo and bio in it is
going to be 30 of the parent
and then everything else the fractional
width belongs to the header
and the words so here's what this looks
like actually
in the grid we've got some nice blue
boxes to help us see how things are put
together
we've got six cells in the grid the
picture is allowed two adjacent cells
labeled photo
the awards is allowed two adjacent cells
marked awards and header and bio
are just in their own individual cells
now again
why wouldn't we wrap divs around this
and just do it all with float
well because grid is simpler and because
responsive
now your designer comes back to you
because again there's just delays and
things and it's a week later and they
say cool
here's the middle of the road uh medium
width
break point version of that component
and now you're like oh
i put a wrapper div around the photo in
the bio and another one about
around the header and the awards and now
i'm in trouble now you gotta refactor
your markup and figure out something
from scratch but if you had used grid
and all four children a photo header
bio and awards were just children of
grid and using grid to lay them out
all you've got to do for this is change
grid template just stick this in a media
query for the right min and max for that
medium zone
and photo and header share a row bio and
awards each become a full row
the photo will only be 150 pixels wide
and header gets the rest of the space
and we've reduced our gap so now it's
one ram both directions instead of
one between rows and three between
columns
and now we're perfectly set up to go one
smaller because you've got your mobile
comp as well
and now we're dropping all the text and
so we're going to do this with our grid
template much
much shorter photo and header are the
only areas we need
notice however we have to explicitly
hide awards and bio
grid will not hide them automatically
simply because
there's no long gray grid template area
that they match
grid is actually very very content
friendly it wants people to read your
website okay
so what it will do is it will create a
bonus row underneath header and throw
the bio in there
and then it'll create another bonus row
underneath the bio and throw the awards
in there
grid will just make up two bonus rows
even though you didn't define them in
grid template
and it will preserve your content so if
you need them invisible
you have to do that manually with css
you have to do it on purpose
grid loves your content and it's not
going to hide it unless you tell it to
we can also do a fun thing with like
image layouts kind of like masonry ish
but this is all manual
i1 is a 2x2 i3 is tall 4 is tall 6 is
tall 8 is wide
and wouldn't you know our grid template
looks just like the output
i1 is a square 3 is tall 4 is all 6 is
tall 8 is wide
and everything is evenly sized this is
the power and the beauty of grid when
you make a grid template it looks
just like your output and when you use
grid template with the
row heights down the edge and the column
widths across the bottom
it's all legible and manageable in one
chunk
of text your css looks like your layout
and it's all in one block i love this
so last thing i want to cover for you is
a couple gotchas some tips and tricks
i've discovered on the way
images assigned to a grid area will obey
the grid cell size and maybe end up
stretched or squished or something
and not in their intrinsic aspect ratio
so either wrap the image in a container
element like a div
that's an okay place for a div wrapper
that means nothing semantically
it's just there to help with the image's
sizing or
cool trick you can make the image object
fit cover in your css
that will tell the image go ahead and
fill the entire grid area but behave
like you're a background image using
background image size
your background size cover and every
browser that supports grid
supports object fit so win-win
animating grids can you do that
[Music]
some browsers can animate between grid
template columns and rows values
if there's a same number you can't go
from three columns to four
that's not an animatable way to do it
and you can't animate between different
units
for example your first column can't
animate from 10 pixels to one
fraction those are just impossible
things gap is a little easier to animate
you'll get more browser support for that
and now you can't animate an element
between two different grid areas
that would be super cool not going to
happen because there's too much layout
complexity
and ie11 got to say a word for ie11
some of you might still support it if we
were all in the same conference room we
i would say raise your hands if you're
still supporting it
i'm really grateful we recently dropped
it on the current projects i've been
working on for last couple years
but yet just recently dropped and got to
refactor and let go of a lot of code
fun fact ie11 was the first browser to
support grid
not fun fact the grid spec wasn't
finalized yet so ie11 implemented its
own
non-standard version of grid spec and
auto prefixer if you configure it to
grid true in its uh
options can help it can emulate some of
the things that i 11 doesn't support
like
named grid areas it cannot backfill or
polyfill
gap ie 11 won't support gap full stop
you can't hack that without a
prefix either so to actually recommend
is not using autoprefixer to do grid
but rather use a fallback layout for css
like something like flex or
or flips or whatever it is that works
best for your team for ie11 and here's
what you do
the layout you give ie11 users is usable
nothing is broken or hidden you use an
older code that's fine
it's a boringer layout it might all just
be one column or two columns
cool everything is going to be
accessible legible
interactive you're not going to hide or
break anything but you're also not going
to use grid and get all the nuance and
cleverness of grid
layout and if you
if you've got a strong ie 11 user base
sadly but true
ie 11 users are at this point largely
used to
significant chunks of the web not
working for them
at all that's bad we don't alienate
people just because of an old browser
they're probably locked into by an
enterprise workplace
or some environmental constraint
if you give them readable usable content
that's in one boring column or some
simplified layout
you've given them a working website and
we're doing better than
i could name some big tech companies
that don't support ie 11 at all
so if you still have to support ie11
because of numbers please give them
fallback css
don't i wouldn't try to use auto
prefixer because you're going in too
many too many issues with gap but
give them fallback css it still looks
usable and is good to go
and that's all i'm james i work at
dockyard i love to talk about grid and
other css things so
i'll be in discord today chat with me
there i'm on twitter at jd steinbach and
you can find my code at github and
myblogget.com
all in the same handle um but i like
james not jd
anyway you all have been a great
audience i assume i'll give you the
benefit of the doubt i'm sure you're a
great audience
thanks so much for tuning in today have
a great day and stay well everyone